il est 13h vous passez à table votre
père vous a préparé son plat
incontournable
gag
incournour minimum
decit je sais pas comment écr le nom trp
vas la même chose c'est incroable bien
si on pas marqué la mme chose je quitte
et je plus jamais avec cet
individ 3 2 1 c'est parti gratin de quoi
de c'est pas possible frérot quand on
était petit c'était les coqu cordon bleu
non c'est pas mais c'est quand on était
petit ça c'est quand on est grand c'est
les de plats de papa il a fait évoluer
ça vers un grtin de
macaron avons-nous eu la même enfance
avonsnous une compcit jeis à tes côtés
est-ce que vous êtes vraiment frère
disnous s' y
a sa pas ce que je fais là en fait là
j'ai un petit doute là